[Müzik]
Peki zaman kavramı nihayetinde kozmozun
kendisinin evrimine dayanır evrene
baktığımızda geçmişte olmuş olayları
gördüğümüzü biliyoruz
gece gökyüzüne baktığımızda etrafın
karanlık olduğunu görürüz
bu çok basit ve klasik olan yöntem bile
bize evrenin sonsuz bir geçmişe sahip
olmadığını gösteriyor Çünkü sonsuz bir
kozmossa gökyüzü sonsuz sayıda yıldızdan
gelen ışıklarla dolu olurdu Evet biz
bunları biliyoruz fakat Albert Einstein
da dahil olmak üzere uzun bir süre bilim
adamları evrenin Durağan ve sonsuz
olduğunu düşündüler
gözlemler O zamandan beri Aslında
genişlediğini ve hızlanan bir oranda
olduğunu göstermiştir bunların hepsinin
sonucu da Big bang'a dayanıyor Aslında
yeterince eski bir ışık ararsak Bang
bang’den gelen kanıtı radyasyonu ve
kozmik mikrodalga arka planını bile
görebiliriz Bunun farkına varmak evrenin
yaşını belirlemede ilk adım olmuştu
ama ben evrenin nasıl başladığından çok
zaman kavramı ile ilgileniyorum
zamanın evrenin her yerinde aynı
olmayışı Fikri fiziğin en kafa
karıştırıcı konularından biridir
bir cisim uzayda ne kadar hızlı hareket
ederse zamanda o cisim için kısalmaya
başlar
zamanı basit ve temel bir şey olarak
düşünürüz
Aslında zamanın karakteristik
özellikleri Tıpkı dünyanın düzlüğü gibi
bakış açımızda beliren hatalardandır
zaman dediğimiz şey karmaşık bir yapılar
katmanlar topluluğudur
zaman içinde evrendeki olaylar düzenli
bir şekilde birbirini izler geçmişler
şimdiler gelecekler geçmiş sabit gelecek
açık ve yine de bunların yanlış olduğu
ortaya çıktı
Einstein zamanın kütleye göre
yavaşladığını anlamadan 10 yıl önce Kıza
göre yavaşladığını fark etti
bunu bir örnekle anlatacağım iki
arkadaşımız olsun Ve bu iki arkadaştan
birinin hareketsiz kalmasını diğerini
dolaşmasını isteyelim bu iki arkadaş
farklı sürelerde yaşarlar hareket eden
kişi daha yavaş yaşlanır saate daha az
geçer elinde bir bitki taşıyorsa
çimlenmesi daha uzun sürer Kısacası
hareket eden her şey için zaman daha
yavaş olur
ancak Bu etkinin hissedilebilir hale
gelebilmesi için çok hızlı hareket
edilmesi gerekiyor Bu tarz deneyler ilk
olarak 1970'lerde Uçaklarda hassas
saatler kullanılarak ölçülmüştür
uçaklardaki saatler yerdekilere göre
daha geride bir zamanı gösterir
Einstein 1970'lerdeki bu gösteriden önce
bile henüz 25 yaşındayken ve
elektromanyetizma okurken zamanın
yavaşladığını anlamıştı
İskoç matematiksel fizikçi James
denklemleriyle elektrik ve manyetizmayı
iyi bir şekilde tanımlamıştır bu
denklemler olağan zaman değişkeni içerir
ama ilginç bir özelliği vardır Eğer
sabit bir hızda seyahat ediyorsanız
zamana farklı bir değişken demediğiniz
sürece Baksanıza denklemleri ölçtüğünüz
şeyi tanımlamaz
matematikçiler maksad'a denklemlerinin
bu tarz özelliğinin farkına varsalar da
bunun ne anlama geldiğini
anlayamamışlardı fakat Einstein bunun
önemini kavradı kısaca özetlersem te
saatinizin dururken ölçtüğü zaman T
değil ise saatinizin hareket halindeyken
ölçtüğü zamandır duran bir saatle
hareket eden bir saatin zamanını farklı
olabileceğini Daha önce kimse Hayal
etmemişti
Bu nedenle hareket eden bir nesne duran
bir nesneden daha kısa süre Yaşar bir
saat daha hastaneyi gösterir bir bitki
daha yavaş büyür demiştim genç bir adam
da daha az rüya görür hareket eden bir
nesne için zaman daralır farklı yerler
için tek bir zaman olmadığı gibi belirli
bir yer için bile tek bir zaman yoktur
bir süre yalnızca bir şeyin hareketiyle
belirli bir yörüngeyle
ilişkilendirilebilir
gezegenler arası uzayda zamanın aynı
şekilde geçtiği yerlerde cisimler düşmez
yüzerler öte yandan burada;
gezegenimizin yüzeyinde her şey aşağı
doğru düşüyor Çünkü aşağıda dünya
tarafından zaman yavaşlıyor
Dolayısıyla Biz kolaylıkla
gözlemleyemesek de zamanın
yavaşlamasının çok önemli etkileri
vardır Onu yüzünden bir şeyler düşer ve
ayaklarımız Yere sağlam basmamıza sağlar
ayaklarımız kaldırma yapışıyorsa bile
Bunun sebebi ayaklarımız için zamanın
başımıza göre daha yavaş akması ve yere
doğal olarak mail etmesidir
çok da ütopik değil aslında
uzaktaki bulutların arkasında yavaşça
kaybolan güneşin batışını izlerken
hareket edenin Güneş değil dönenin dünya
olduğunu anlamamız gibi
düşen nesneler Tabi ki bizim gibi
Einstein'ın da dikkatini çekmişti
Einstein Yer çekimi kuvvetini incelerken
şu soruyu sordu güneş ve dünya
birbirlerine dokunmadan ve aralarında
hiçbir şey kullanmadan birbirlerini
nasıl çekebilir
ve bu soruya güneşle dünyanın birbirini
doğrudan çekmediğini hayal ederek bir
açıklama buldu
Bunun yerine ikisinin de aralarındaki
uzay ve zamanı kademeli olarak hareket
ettirdiklerini düşündü Tıpkı suya
batırılmış birinin etrafındaki suyu
değiştirmesi gibi
zamanın yapısındaki bu değişikliğin
cisimlerin hareketini etkileyerek
onların düşmelerine veya birbirlerine
doğru çekilmelerine neden olduğunu buldu
zamanın esnekte olduğu da bilinen bir
gerçektir mesela zaman dağlarda deniz
seviyesine göre daha hızlı Akar evet
fark çok küçüktür ama internetten birkaç
bin dolara satın alabileceğiniz
saatlerle Bunlar ölçülebilir uzman da
laboratuvarların saatlerini
kullanırsakta sadece birkaç santimetre
arayla seviyeler arasındaki bu
yavaşlamayı tespit edebiliriz
yerdeki bir saat bile masada kinden
Biraz daha yavaş çalışır tabi yavaşlayan
sadece saatler değildir
daha aşağı indiğimizde tüm süreç çok
yavaştır bu sefer bu iki arkadaştan
birini daha diğerini ovaya koyalım
Yıllar Sonra onları tekrar
buluşturduğumuzda dağdaki arkadaşın daha
çabuk yaşlandığını görürüz ovadaki ise
daha az yaşamış daha az yaşlanmıştır
daha somut olmak adına gerçek hayatta
yapılmış bir gözlemden örnek vermek
istiyorum
Natur fiziksel yayınlanan Bu gözlemde
iki tane saatten biri Alp dağlarına
Diğeri ise İtalya turnadaki bir
laboratuvara konmuş aralarında bir
kilometre olan bu iki saatten alplerde
olan daha ileride bir zamanı
göstermiştir
dünya yüzeyindeki biri merkezden
merkezden yaklaşık 6.371 km yüksekte
olacaktır mesela Şuradaki ovada biri
olduğunu düşünelim O zamanı bu kadar
saniye olarak benimleyecektir aynı bir
saniyeye bu kadar yerine bu kadar
deneyimleyebilmek için yani sadece
9-09'dan sonraki sayıyı değiştirmek için
Dünya yüzeyinden 1020 kilometre yani
merkezden 7.391 km uzaklıkta olmak
gerekir yani Merak etmeyin üst kat
komşumuz bizden daha hızlı yaşlanmaz
ama yine de belli bir süre sonra
ayağımıza taktığımız bir saat
elimizdekinden daha geri olacaktır
Peki zaman bükülürse ne olur bir cisim
uzayda ne kadar hızlı hareket ederse
zamanda o cisim için kısalmaya başlar
cisim Işık hızına ulaştığında ise
bükülme gerçekleşir ışığın yolu uzadığı
zaman bükülen uzayda zamanın akışı da
lokal olarak yavaşlar Işık aynı zamanda
neden sonuç ilişkisinin Özünde fizik
kuvvetlerinin
yani nedenselliğin hızı olduğu için
zamanın akışını yavaşlar Dolayısıyla
kütle uzay zamanı büküyor diyoruz
kısaca ışığın yolu uzadığı vakit bükülen
uzayda zaman da yavaşlar bu durum uzayda
fiziksel olarak maddelerinde Önemli olan
da etkiler
Sonuç olarak uzayda zaman kavramı var mı
sorusuna bir matematik modeli ile yanıt
verebiliriz Bu Matematik modeli uzaylı
zaman sürekli adı verilen yapıda
birleştir
ilmiş uzay zaman düzlemi bildiğimiz 3
boyutu 4 olan zaman ile birleştirir
Isaac Newton'ın fizik yasaları büyük
nesnelerin hareketini tanımlıyor
jamesik bir modellemeleri ise ışığın
özelliğini açıklıyordu Bunlar sayesinde
ilerlendi Albert Einstein'ın Görelilik
teorisi ile de uzay zaman kavramı
geliştirildi
bütün Benim anlattığım bu şeylere ve
bütün bu ilerlemelere rağmen bilim
adamları oluşturdukları modellerin
yetersiz kaldığını farkındalar
teşekkürler
[Alkış]